So, several years ago, I was in a brand new apartment.
I woke up in the middle of the night to do something, I don't remember what it was.
As I went back to bed, I rammed my toe so hard into the bed frame that I ended up breaking my toe.
I didn't know I broke it until I woke up the next morning.
It was black and blue.
My whole foot was all messed up.
And I limped around for days.
There was nothing that could be done about it because I just simply broke my toe.
The bed wasn't new, but the apartment was.
And when I woke up, it was pitch black.
I couldn't see a thing.
So naturally, I was so disoriented, didn't know where I was, didn't know what was going on,
that I forgot where the bed was because I forgot where I was.
Now, see, growing up in my younger days as an early baby Christian,
that's kind of how I thought of faith.
I thought of faith as sort of this wandering in the darkness trying to figure something out,
hoping that I don't stub my toe and hope I don't do something kind of dumb.
And in reality, in my life, I actually did stub my toe to the point where I walked away for quite some time.
And as I came back to the church, I realized something that faith is not at all like wandering in the darkness.
And what I've discovered is that so many students still kind of have that belief
that it's just either attaching themselves to what their parents believe
and simply just going along with something or literally wandering around in the darkness,
hoping that what they believe is somehow true
and that somehow in the end of all things, when this life ends,
that they'll find out that it is actually true.
What's interesting, though, is that John says something in the very end of his gospel
that starts to speak to us about really what faith actually is.
And it's in John chapter 20, verses 30 and 31.
And John says this,
Jesus did many other miracles or miraculous signs in the presence of his disciples,
which are not recorded in this book,
but these are written that you may believe
that Jesus is the Christ, the Son of God,
and that by believing you may have life in his name.
What's interesting is what John says to you is that these miraculous signs,
all of these things that John has recorded in his gospel
are so that you might believe were given reasons.
And what's fascinating about the gospel of John is the seven miraculous signs that John gives,
starting with Jesus turning water into wine
and then ending with this magnitude kind of a miracle with the raising of Lazarus.
And then if you want to include the eighth one of Jesus' own resurrection,
is that time after time, John sets it up
so that we see increasing in measure all these signs that Jesus is exactly who he says he is.
And this is what we want students to actually get,
that biblical faith is trust based on evidence
and that translates really into a deeper relationship.
I mean think about the relationships that you have.
You don't just blindly trust somebody that you don't know,
but the more you get to know somebody, the more you trust them.
The more you trust them, the deeper that relationship starts to go.
And this is sort of how relationships work.
It's no different with our relationship with Christ.
The more we know who he is, the more we know about what's going on
and what the gospel is, the more we can trust
and the more reason we have to trust in what God is doing through Christ.
And the more that we do that, the deeper our relationship with him goes.
And this is exactly why we start in this lesson
with this idea of your students trust between friends.
We want them to get that sense of what that looks like
because our best and deepest relationships are built on a sense of trust,
a deep sense of trust.
And we have that because that person has either continually provided reasons to trust them
or maybe not reasons to trust them.
So we want our students to be able to see how that works.
And what's really even more fascinating I think
is when we start thinking about what faith is and how this works
we naturally kind of find ourselves in Hebrews 11, right?
Hebrews 11 1.
Now faith is being sure of what we hope for
and certain of what we do not see.
This is what the ancients were commended for.
And then the writer of Hebrews goes through that huge wall of faith
of all these people that had the right kind of faith.
And we use this verse as sort of the foundational piece of what faith means, right?
Being sure of what we hope for and certain of what we do not see.
Well, that word's certain.
The word actually means, or it has with it,
the idea of a foundation or substructure.
So think of it this way. It's a basement.
The idea that the writer is talking about is the basement in your home.
When you walk downstairs into your basement,
if you have one or if you've ever walked into a basement,
you generally don't fear that the whole house is going to cave in on you, right?
Because you've walked down to a basement,
it has these huge metal beams and these metal poles
and they're driven into the cement, into the ground
and the whole house is being held up by these beams and this basement.
And when you walk downstairs, you don't think anything of it.
Why?
Because the house is built out of solid foundation
and if foundation in the house is cracked,
the house is starting to be no good
and you can't really do anything in the house until you fix the foundation.
So that's what the writer is saying.
He's saying that it's so sure, so fundamental
that you can walk into a house and feel totally confident
so much so that you don't even think about it.
That's what faith is.
It's that foundational piece of what we do not see.
It's assurance of it.
And in fact, if you take it one step deeper,
the root word comes from the idea of an idea
or one who stands immovable.
It cannot be moved at all.
One who is so rock solid and so dug into a foundation
that it can't be moved.
That is what our faith is and that's what we want students to be able to see.
I mean, think about it for a second.
I was just thinking about this the other day.
Why did Jesus keep his wounds?
Why would Jesus, he's Jesus.
He resurrects and yet in the end of John's gospel,
he shows Thomas his wounds.
Thomas wants to see them.
He wants to see for himself what it is that Jesus...
Why? It's Jesus.
He's resurrected.
What more evidence do you need?
Right?
But Jesus keeps his wounds.
And I've always found that really fascinating
that out of all things that Jesus could have done,
we'd be like, well, I'm going to fix these wounds
because why would I want to have these holes in my wrist
and this gash in my side?
Why would I want to keep those?
One more reason, even if it was just for Thomas,
one more reason to show that this is who I am
and I've done exactly what I said I was going to do.
So, faith.
We want our students to really understand the deep roots of faith
that it's not wandering in the darkness,
but it's assurance and evidence of belief.
So our small group time should be something
that students can take a step back
and think about it and discuss with each other
what it really means to have faith.
And I want your students to start
and you should encourage your students to start
thinking about, well, do I have my own faith
or am I still just believing what my parents believed
or what other people have told me to believe
or am I starting to now believe things on my own
based on what I'm now discovering
and that starts with asking your students,
have they considered the evidence?
Have they considered all of the tools that are in here,
especially that God has given us to figure out
is what Jesus did and what God is doing
and the whole of salvation history?
Is that enough?
So what we're talking about is finding a space
where students can start to make their faith their own.
It's easy for us as leaders to stand up in front of
a bunch of students and tell them about our faith
and read through scripture and give them
an interpretation of what our faith looks like
and what faith they ought to have based on our faith.
But it's a whole different thing
and the thing that we want you to start
to encourage students to this transfer
of what we're telling them to believe
and what they believe based on the evidence
that they're discovering on their own begins to happen
is we want you to create a space
where students can invest, they can pursue on their own,
they can go back to the idea of questions,
they can ask the right questions
or ask any questions for that matter
so that the evidence that's here in scripture
will come right off the page and into their lives.
That's the kind of faith that sticks.
That's the kind of faith that they'll take with them to college.
That's the kind of faith that we want them to have.
We don't want to just them to accept what we're telling them.
We want them to discover that what we're telling them
is actually true.
So three things to keep in mind.
One, drive home the fact that biblical faith
is not without evidence.
Biblical faith is not without evidence.
Number two, that Jesus has taken significant time
and energy to give us that evidence.
And finally, number three,
for students considering the evidence,
it opens the door to a much deeper
and more meaningful relationship
with the creator of the world.